i'm in a bad place i just hit for 19
million dollars but i'm going down fast
and hard tyson fury went through
something similar right i had a vision i
had money he wanted to talk about some
of these some of the greatest challenges
outside of the ring showed me all the
drugs all the cocaine it was like scar
things like a movie
i was like champ you bugging what are
you doing you don't ever put no hands on
the brownsville yeti
i don't know where you from yeti get
them yeah
all over the world it didn't work for me
alcohol didn't work for me 10 years
clean this month yes
[Music]
that's right praise the beat that's
right
[Music]
are you ready
[Music]
now my next guest is a former
heavyweight champion world champion
and has fought some of the best in the
world like george foreman klitschko
lennox lewis you name it he's probably
fought him but what we really want to
talk to
him about are some of the
biggest and greatest battles outside of
the ring that he has gone up against and
how he overcame them
like going into a deep depression
becoming obese even at one point trying
to kill himself with food and money
growing up an orphan and much much more
so we can go ahead and get to know
our next guest
champ shannon briggs what's up brother
let's go champ how are you doing how are
you doing i'm good champ how about
yourself good good good it's nice to
have you here on the dean show with us
thank you for having me chad i really
appreciate that so did we hit that right
uh
world champion you've fought some of the
greatest out there huh well you got that
wrong since it's two-time anyway
yeah okay so multi heavyweight champ of
the world huh i'd rather yes chad
yeah so tell us some of the some of the
greats that you fought i mentioned linux
lewis you got george foreman uh
klitschko
yes yes i'm sure those those those are
some of the champions of ford as well as
uh francois botha sergey lankovic
uh
just to name a few uh sultan and
bragging off is one of my top title
challenges
uh vitalicasco yeah i i had a couple
fights here and there
and you're still ticking strong huh yeah
i'm still feeling good you know i'm in
great shape i just turned 50 this in the
fourth uh i have an upcoming match uh
with uh rampage jackson look at him
y'all pretty big dude don't
i'm looking forward to that we're going
to fight three fights possibly uh one in
the triad ring which is a which is a new
combat um
formal combat that was created through
trilla and uh then we're gonna fight and
buy the boxing ring and i'm gonna knock
him out again and then we're gonna fight
a mma mma match in which uh he thinks
he's gonna choke me but that's not gonna
happen
okay for the mma uh and uh hopefully god
willing like we say inshallah maybe we
could be of benefit that's that's my
specialty that's what i teach uh uh
gracie brazilian jiu jitsu so maybe we
can get you out over at our academy and
we can uh give you some good techniques
to help defend the choke and maybe apply
some good submission on him turn the
tables yeah i'm gonna definitely need
your help because that's that's the area
that i'm not too good at but i'm sure
with your help you'll help me get them
get it get them up off me we say
inshallah god willing beautiful
yes so tell me now what we wanted to
talk about some of these some of the
greatest challenges outside of the ring
i mean you've gone through a lot you
know in your struggles you went through
one time a really deep depression you
know obesity that's something that's an
epidemic today in in not just america
all over the world but especially here
70 people 70 percent of americans either
overweight or obese you know uh
depression is at an all-time high
skyrocketing people just you know
throwing down the uh prescription drugs
and you know thinking that's gonna help
but you kind of overcame these things
even at one point really trying to kill
you and your life can you talk to us a
little bit how you went down that road
and how you got out
well it was you know it was like i
always say it's not just one thing it
was a multitude of things you know
growing up
uh you know
tough childhood
like most kids and then uh you know
coming into success of somewhat
and always really struggling to get
ahead and led to a lot of different
things bad decision making at some point
and then uh unfortunately i had my box
for food and uh
you know prescription drugs and it led
to more depression unfortunately for me
my daughter was born
and she'll be 10 january 15th and
congratulations thank you when she was
born i took a huge step towards our
recovery which was uh actually this this
this
next week i believe it is this week will
be 10 years clean no alcohol i haven't
had it that would be 10 years my
daughter it was a week or two before my
daughter was born um
i told myself that i was done drinking
alcohol and that's when i gave him
alcohol
and i i i was a journey which was to
to health and my health and
wealth to be honest with you because
i've always been on my own since i was
eight years old i've been doing some
full of employment working trying to
survive um to take care of me and my mom
single parent in brownsville brooklyn
beyond so for me um
i've always been working and struggling
to
earn so
i took a spiritual
journey to wealth and health which is
training hard eating right and which is
my health and then also using that same
um drive that i've always had to build
some wealth and i could i created then i
trademarked the uh
let's go champ and i was to
to it was my my my uh
my self motivation my trigger word for
what i was feeling depressed and
you know i wanted to quit or i wanted to
give up i tell myself let's go channel
let's go channel and it became my mantra
um and i went around the world
and you know i think so in some ways
it's synonymous when you hear let's go
champ some people think of shedding
breaks you know mm-hmm
so then tyson fury went through
something similar right i had everything
i had money fame
glory good looks i had it all everything
that a man would ever want
you can have everything in the world and
feel like
uh he also hit a deep depression and i'm
thinking like how is that when people
you know the whole world opens up to you
got all this money fame how do you end
up going down that route
well that's what you know that
contributes to it as well because
everybody got a hole in you
and then you know you get you disappear
whole with money coming through or you
know you kind of pick up things sometime
to you to distract you to coach you to
make you feel like okay to numb you in
some ways
you're doing things to chase uh our
feelings you know all goes down to
chemicals in your brain dopamine
serotonin and different things and
sometimes you know we start chasing this
dopamine high or serotonin high it's
hard to matter whether it's alcohol
drugs gambling sex whatever it is these
things are chemical in the brain you
know that that these reactions so i i
myself
even food like i was saying uh i myself
had to
to fulfill it with exercise now you
think that
i mean as a professional boxer that i've
been doing it all my life basically
since i was 16 years old that
uh i would have known that but i didn't
know how important exercise was to me
and my life until i stopped exercising i
ballooned up and weight so you know 400
pounds and i realized that uh exercise
was a crucial part of my life not just
from a physical standpoint but from a
mental standpoint that even now when i
don't exercise i don't feel great we all
know uh exercises releases uh different
chemicals they sell it the uh the run is
high these these things are
these things are real and these things
are like
any added or anyone chasing anything a
high or feel good
um you know
i it took me to
to hit you know a real low pace in my
life to realize that
um i needed to fulfill
my
so-called like desire whether it was to
go out and spend money you know go buy a
new car buy this buy buy buy material
stuff all these things were
proud of me and then i started realizing
you got to replace that replace that
with something positive you know what i
thought i dove head first into eating
right into health like okay what what's
the best food i started going to
anti-aging because i wanted to know how
i could lose the weight feel good you
know look good feel good that was that's
the key part of it you know look good
feel good so i was i was looking messy i
started changing myself how i love my
appearance and i started feeling good
and i realized that that in itself kept
me occupied wasn't it going out drinking
spots spending money
anything except anything just it became
more fulfilling and it cost less
and it caught
yeah people can't you have you have uh
at one point you said using you're using
money to kill yourself like yeah yeah
everybody but you know you're buying
money for heroin or for cracking
anything using the same money using it
but i was just using it in ways like
just so to numb myself like to feel good
so let me go do this let me buy this let
me go to this let me go get a girl let
me do it and all those things just have
you chasing the tail listen it didn't
work for me alcohol didn't work for me
10 years clean this month can you
believe it you know what i'm saying i'm
not actually 10 years alcohol free i had
started drinking alcohol as a homeless
teenager at the age of 13 14 years old
uh on and off drinking with the boys
drinking beer here this and that but uh
after you know 10 years cleaning alcohol
i lost the taste i lost the desire i
didn't like what it did to me and i look
back and say a lot of my decision making
was based on alcohol especially when it
came to spending money because you know
it was part of that life being being out
spending money drinking and then i go
shopping is this a routine that was it
was a brutal routine but i'm happy i
overcame it i'm happy i'm able to tell
people that hey listen
you know i'm actually helping a friend
right now i'm not gonna
say his name but
i got a call from a friend of mine who
said who said champ uh i'm in a bad
place i just hit for 19 million dollars
and i uh but i'm going down fast and
hard because i'm doing drugs
and i'm partying every day for the last
three months since the deal here because
he disappeared and i hadn't heard from i
was like what happened you know i mean
what happened to my boy not even
thinking nothing happened just kind of
curious because i kept calling i didn't
get him on the phone when i finally got
him on the phone he said chad yesterday
he said chad
you haven't heard from me because the
deal went through now i wasn't part of
the deal i'm just you know he got 19
million 19 million 19 million and then
now he's calling you saying i'm going
down fast i called him yo you called him
and i just had to ask him a question
a business question and i was lucky to
get him on the phone because i called
him quite a few times over the last
three months and he never answered
so i was like man what's up you know did
i do something to him he answered
yesterday he was like jim
you haven't heard from me because i hate
for 19 million and look he showed me his
house he showed me i was like wow
congratulations he was like yeah but
look he showed me all the drugs all the
cocaine it was like scar things like a
movie
i was like champ you bugging what are
you doing he said i know i never had
money i never lived life and now i've
been doing it for two months and i got
the money but i see i'm going to kill
myself the way i'm headed i said i said
listen to me
you need a champ camp
you need a champ camp
yeah you need a champion you need to
awaken somebody to tell you your champ
you bugging out chill out
chill and he was like you're right he
was like chip can you come with can you
come malibu and and hang out with me and
get me clean i was like i don't know
what you can't but i say that to say
this
his endorphins is high right now he's
growing crazy right and the money is
making him it's making him go crazy
you know i mean he could crash he's 30
years old he can crash
and do a lot of damage so
i say that to say i'm happy that
i was able to talk to him
and
through my experiences people can learn
and say yo
champ was right
a lot of people don't have a lot of
people will have a big brother a father
a uncle they don't have anybody in their
life to say hey man
you're doing wrong
and um
i'm lucky to say that i survived my my
my hiccup hiccups
and i can tell people hey man
you know don't do it chad
yeah that's why we're trying to get some
gems trying to see from your experiences
so uh god when people can benefit uh
from some of the
things that you've gotten over
uh did you actually get a chance did you
know you do you know personally uh tyson
fury did you guys ever
meet in the ring before
no we never fought never after i had
came out of my depression
i had lost weight yeah
he i had seen the ran into him and i was
telling hey man he was at a bad place at
the time yeah i was like hey man you can
do it man if i did it you could do it he
was like nah nah i said no man i'm
telling you you can do it and he did it
i was in a dark room on my own
and i was praying to god
to
and not only help
he do he was the biggest house he did it
he did it big he won the title he put on
some of the best fights in history now
you know was wilder
and um you know
i'm happy i'm happy that he was able to
he told me he looked at me he was like
yo
you inspired me so i'm happy for man i'm
happy i was able to inspire him and
i'm still hoping to inspire as many
people as i can
how much uh did uh muhammad ali did he
play any role in um
in your life for every role
he's our michael jordan you know
he's not michael jordan
you never did you ever get a chance to
meet did you ever get a chance to meet
uh muhammad ali
yeah i met muhammad ali when i was um 23
years old i believe for the first time
maybe i was younger i'm sorry i was 20
when i met ali for the first time
and uh yeah it was it was in yeah 1992 i
believe
and uh
yeah he was an amazing
you know speaking of life for all of us
tell me uh at one point you also met
mike tyson tell us about that experience
the first time you met him in a park
no i didn't meet him then but i seen him
you saw him yeah when you saw him yes
yeah he was a you know
a specimen of a man as he as a young man
mike tyson was a special specimen of a
man and he still is he's one of the
greatest heavyweight fighters in the
history of the planet of this world of
this world and uh that we know unboxing
and you know
it's a pleasure to be you know it's an
honor to be from the same
neighborhood that he's from you know
yeah i want to go ahead and get your
reaction to uh this
uh video here i want us i want to see if
you if you know some of these
individuals in the video that i'm going
to play with for you are you ready
can you recognize anybody in these
videos
yeah i don't see you girl but i see you
i think that's bad
that's a good friend he's a good friend
of yours right yes is that bad that's
bad yes badou jack where's my brother
yeah yeah how about who's next to him
is that mike
that's mike wow let's go john
mike tyson
and then you know uh who's leading
leading them have you ever seen anything
like this
am i seeing you like what like like like
yeah
men brain
yeah i mean this type of this type of
praying have you ever seen
you know what they're doing
man i'm born
okay so that's familiar to you yeah man
of course so okay so you you met some
muslims before
man i'm from brooklyn i was born in
brooklyn new york brown yeah
yeah
i was a little i was a little nervous
you'd be nervous on coming on an islamic
tv show
why should i be scared yeah with all the
with all the negative propaganda that's
out there a lot of times people you know
they get a little bit nervous but uh
that's why we do the program to try to
break some of the ice and educate uh
humanity on the most misunderstood way
of life out there that actually muhammad
ali lived malcolm x and then we got uh
mike tyson here praying with uh badu
jack so you know about who jack huh and
uh you gotta you got uh amir abdullah
you know him also his manager
yeah so when you mention brooklyn why
there's a lot a lot of muslims there in
uh brooklyn new york period there's a
lot of muslims in new york there's a lot
of muslims in the world all over the
world
yeah
so the next thing before we conclude i
want to that's what my next thing i
wanted to see get you have you ever
heard this i'm going to i'm gonna let
you hear it and just get your reaction
to it and uh your feedback here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what does that sound like to you have
you ever heard that being in new york
has that ever
have you ever heard never never if you
have to guess i mean you've listened to
a lot of music probably hip-hop 50 cents
55 cents all this stuff up what is that
what did that sound like to you
what do you mean
like you know you know you can classify
if it's jazz you classify jazz if it's
rock you'll classify rock hip-hop you
know the beast of hip-hop what category
does this fit into when you're listening
to it
definitely not rock it's not rapid it's
a foreign language to me
and it's a foreign music it's not a sign
it doesn't sound
it sounds like you know someone's
singing i don't understand the language
but yeah you know it sounds beautiful
for what it's worth i mean the voice i'm
showing i don't know what they're
singing about
it sounds beautiful
mashallah yeah
yeah this is uh this is the quran
this is the quran
yeah okay that's cool beautiful
beautiful
so uh
so what message can you give before we
conclude um tell us um for the people
out there who are suffering you know
this is a beautiful thing when you put
in your mind when you're at the depths
you know the lowest places in your life
and i like this mantra that you can you
know you're putting in your head you
know uh let's go champ you know you can
do it just like when this your friend
called you he's got the money and now
he's going down that's that's crazy he's
like hey i haven't reached you because
you know i hit it he pretty much hit it
big but now you would think he's got all
the money it's going to bring happiness
but it's not filling that void you know
what i mean not at all and that's why
you asked me to come help him beside
your champ i need your help i need a
champ camp so i'm that i would say like
to say i'm lucky to be that type of
person that someone will look at me and
say i just got 19 million
and i would love for you to come help me
and get behind together that's amazing
that means that they respect or see
something and like he said
i see what you overcame with a lot more
money
so he was like you know i can use your
help but um
you know i think you know life's a
journey chat we all
we on the journey we are trying to make
it we are trying to do the right thing
hopefully and uh you know i want to
appreciate you for having me on your
show
thank you very much scott william we can
uh so you're in miami huh yes brother
yes champ all right so hopefully if we
ever visit down there we can we can uh
you know and if you're ever in chicago
oh you're in
delicious chicago in chicago that's my
place man yeah we can have you come by
our our our gym our accountability here
i would love to man
i'm saying i'm gonna have to train with
you i can show you how to beat rampage
so wait tell me so that's you said it's
a it's a a three part you're doing one
thing with rampage for boxing and then
the other one is uh what were the other
two triads
form of combat it's like you fight with
ufc gloves like i mean well mma gloves
uh but you kind of like dirty boxing you
know what i'm saying it's like you're
fighting a triangle ring i triangle you
know
the matter is a triangle
so wait you're so but the boxing you're
gonna do that's how many how many ounce
gloves that's the uh eight ounce right
boxing is gonna be i think 10 ounces or
something like that but these are gonna
be i think four of them you know no
these are eight ounce gloves these are
eight ounces
yeah so
you're gonna do one with the regular
boxing then the other one with these uh
with these other type of mma gloves the
mma gloves first triad event which
should be uh
probably in may and then uh
wow so that's is that anything on the
ground or is that just strictly you know
uh specifically stand up stand up he
gonna be on the ground when i hit him
[Laughter]
and then two of those and then the third
one is is uh
on everything mma is that is that in the
ufc
well it's in the cave it's in the cage
i know yeah
okay yeah all right that's what i'm
gonna joke that's what i'm gonna put up
that's what i'm gonna get him on the
ground and i'm gonna choke him so he
can't breathe until he begged me to quit
god bless you
god bless you champ all right thank you
very much it was nice it was nice having
you on the program guys see that fist
you see that fist yeah get that champ
all it take is one hit
one champ one
are you still doing the molasses
oh how do you know about the molasses
you're still doing the molasses
what do you do real quick uh just i
forgot to ask you like in the morning
like what do you like to eat what what's
your new regimen for example
onions liver liver and onions oh
you're doing the liver
that's the most that liver is the most
neutral nutritiously dense food out
there that many people don't know about
that that's right
i'm eating like an animal i'm eating
beef
chicken fish i'm getting this tip-top
shake by my animal you're gonna see me
soon chad when rampage see me he's gonna
all right beautiful
all right very nice man may god bless
you and and um
uh we hope to uh maybe meet you in
person sometimes too right that's right
praise the god praise god let's go check
it
out
let's go
and that was the uh
former world heavyweight champion
shannon briggs here on the dean show
uh there's a couple lessons that we got
to learn you know we wanted to talk
about
what helped him get out
you know of this depression
he was into
a lot of the things like you know that
people get into once you got all that
money so one lesson is you can have all
the money you know the story he
uh shared with us his friend got the 19
million
and he's heading downhill and you would
think okay because many people chase
money so now you got money what are you
going to do with that money so like
shannon was sharing with us he was just
eating himself to death he was going
ahead and doing the drugs and alcohol
and all the different things that a
person would think
that would bring them some sort of
happiness but it's just term and short
lived it's just fulfilling your desires
but the void is still there
so inshallah we can go ahead and um
benefit from that for people who are
trying to you know chase all the
material things and finding and dining
and you know just running through life
heedless on the purpose of life to
really think you know yes money can be a
means for you to go ahead and do some
good in the world but it can also lead
to your destruction
and we need to really think what's the
purpose of life why am i here everything
around us has a purpose the keys in my
pocket have a purpose you know this uh
the camera that's filming this has a
purpose you know everything
that we can see in front of us but what
about the human being what's our purpose
and what's the purpose of life you know
pretty soon he'll be in the ring and he
will be facing rampage jackson now
imagine that these two get into this
octagon try got whatever this thing is
that they're going to be doing and there
was no ultimate
goal at the end there was no
objective
that would make no sense now go ahead
and equate that to life what is the
purpose of our lives and many of us are
heading towards our departure date many
have already departed from this life you
know where do we go when we leave so
those are the kind of crucial questions
that we should be asking what's the
purpose of life why are we here and who
best to ask than the one who created us
the creator of heavens and earth so we
leave you with that and if you'd like a
free copy of what you heard shannon
listening to which is the vibrated word
of god almighty allah the quran go ahead
and visit the deenshow.com you can get
your free copy of the quran and if you
have any questions call us
1-800-662-4752
and subscribe if you haven't already hit
that notification
bell support us on our patreon page and
we'll see you next time here every week
on the dean show
thank you to our special guest former
heavyweight champ let's go champ shannon
for being with us
and we'll see you next time peace be
with you assalamu alaikum